mentally ill and violent jaunty bravery
told his carers he wanted to hurt or
kill someone alone and unsupervised at
the Tate Modern Art Gallery he carried
out his threat he grabbed a six-year-old
boy threw him a hundred feet from a
viewing gantry and almost killed him
witnesses said he shrugged and laughed
at what he'd just done he told the boy's
father yes I am mad after seeing the
attacker jailed a detective read a
statement from the young boy's family
the acts committed by this individual
against our son is unspeakable
words cannot express the horror and the
fear that his actions have brought upon
us and our son he was now wondering why
is in hospital how can one explain to a
child that someone deliberately tried to
kill him from what the doctor said he
has many years of physiotherapy ahead of
him and we have no prospects or plan for
the future
other than being by his side the boy on
holiday from France suffered multiple
fractures and a bleed on his brain he is
still in a wheelchair today wear splints
on his left arm and both his legs and
spends his days in a corset molded his
waist sat in his wheelchair the nights
are always extremely difficult his sleep
is very agitated he is in pain he wakes
up many times and he cries jaunty
bravery suffers from autism spectrum
disorder a behavioural condition but the
judge said that did not explain his
attack on the boy mrs. Justice McGowan
told him the fear he must have
experienced and the horror his parents
felt are beyond imagination you had
intended to kill someone that day you
almost killed that six-year-old boy you
will spend the greater part if not all
of your life detained you may never be
released
social services had been supervising the
teenager since he was a juvenile he was
in supported accommodation but allowed
out alone for
for hours at a time the council said the
case was being reviewed and it would
learn from the findings
jaunty bravery is being treated at
Broadmoor secure Hospital his parents
said they could never forgive him but
felt they had been let down by the
system Martin Brant Sky News